Jake I need Mary to do the news where
she really I can't believe one to do
this sawsbuck I choose you mary did the
freaking news welcome to our top five
news stories of the week and our annual
Halloween costume contest first up we
have Marty McFly and for our first news
story PSN sent on a survey asking if you
wanted to change your PSN username yes
yes I do Sony sent out a survey asking
ps4 users what they think are the most
important features that should be added
to the console the survey was posted
online by neogaf user saint of killers
among the choices are much requested
features like the ability to change your
network ID custom background and a hide
completely remove item from library
functions also found on the list of
options are psone classics and ps2
classics indicating the platform holder
may be gauging the demand for
re-releases one of the features
mentioned PlayStation Store wish list
was added on october 23rd currently the
functionality is only accessible through
the web version of the PlayStation Store
it's unclear when will be added to the
console store the survey also asks when
respondents expect PlayStation to
release the next big system software
update with a range of timeframe
starting from before the end of 2015 and
going up to 2017 or later next up is all
the fallout 4 news there's baseball bats
and leak controls and trophies oh my
Bethesda has released some baseball
themed fallout 4 gameplay footage
there's a big leagues perk which allows
players to do double damage with a melee
weapons like the beast up baseball bat
there was also a fallout 4 manual leaked
to the Xbox SmartGlass app revealing the
game's default control scheme new of
bilities and more the Xbox one controls
include new options for a bash attack
and sprint grenades are thrown by
holding down the right bumper while
pressing the left bumper brings up the
VATS shooting screen EXO phase has
obtained the ps4 trophy list we'd expect
these to be pretty similar for Xbox one
and PC versions of the game fallout 4
will reward you for completing missions
recruiting companions collecting
bobbleheads hacking terminals crafting
items killing people and creatures kill
300 people and you'll unlock the mass
whole trophy achievement which is a riff
on the popular word for what you call
someone from Massachusetts when they're
acting like a jerk I could go on but it
gets a bit spoiler heavy and the game
comes out November 10th oh my god oh my
god oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my
god oh my god the next story is the
first major Xbox one update including
the first known backwards compatibility
game oh the update completely redesigns
the system's dashboard reworks the guide
and changes the snap feature it also
introduces backwards compatibility for a
select number of xbox 360 games the
feature first became available earlier
this year for preview program members
with more games slowly being added over
the last several months also we've
learned the critically acclaimed 2008
racing game burnout paradise is the next
360 game that will be playable on Xbox
one if you were thinking about heading
back to GTA online now is the time
because they have a massive halloween
update but only if you're cool enough to
have current gen GTA 5 is celebrating
Halloween with a special in-game event
Rockstar released spooky items like cars
and maps as well as a slasher themed
adversary mode there's two new weird
vehicles the lurcher hearse in the
frankenstein in addition rockstars added
20 ghoulish bobbleheads that can be
added to any new lowrider car the
halloween update also brings new masks
for height you'll find these in the
Halloween masks category in the monsters
section of the spooky movie map store in
addition rockstar has added 13 ooh
spooky face paint options to help you
celebrate the holiday
quit trying to make halo 5 split-screen
happens it's never going to happen the
fact that halo 5 guardians does not
offer split screen has been a
much-discussed point ever since
Microsoft made the announcement earlier
this year in a new interview Halo
franchise development director Frank
O'Connor says the blowback has been huge
though there are no plans to add
split-screen to halo 5 in an interview
with GamesRadar O'Connor said that it
would be technically impossible to add
split-screen to halo 5 as a patch the
game 60 FPS framerate is partially
responsible for this when 343 made the
decision have halo 5 run at a lock to 60
frames per second the team did so with
the understanding it would create issues
and technical impossibilities for the
rest of the game O'Connor added that he
personally enjoys split screen but said
that the number of people who actually
play Halo games via local split screen
is small relative to the total player
base finally he teased that it's
possible for halo 6 to have split screen
so those were our top five news stories
of the week and the best Halloween
costumes we had to offer I know they
were okay that's it for us here have an
awesome Halloween and we'll see you next
week with jeff mcdonald taking back the
reins GS news